the question i'm always getting is what
about living what about spending on
things that you love what about
clothes what about fashion do i have to
just go
spartan i can't buy any of that stuff
hi mr wonderful here and welcome to
another episode of
ask mr wonderful this week i have to
address a question i'm getting
thousands of it's the same one over and
over again
it's always this you talk about saving
money and not spending any money
and that has to be part of your protocol
how you live your life and you have to
invest
not just save i've talked about this
dozens of times
but that means you can't buy anything
you're always taking 100 bucks a week
which is what i say you should do
and investing it over the long period
because the markets give you somewhere
between a six and eight percent return
over long periods of time yes they go up
and down
but the whole idea i've been talking
about is
taking a portion of your salary let's
say you only make 56
000 a year the average salary and you
take a hundred bucks a week
and you start investing it not saving it
in the savings account because that
doesn't pay any interest anymore but
putting it into the stock market
and letting it grow over 30 40 years
if you do that and you have that
discipline you'll end up
a millionaire in your 60s where you
really need to have some money
to retire with as much as a million and
a half dollars so i think that's a
pretty pragmatic strategy where did i
learn that
from my mother georgette but the
question i'm always getting is
what about living what about spending on
things that you love what about
clothes what about fashion what about
all the things that i want to buy
do i do i have to just go spartan i
can't buy any of that stuff
not true i want you to have a different
mindset when you
purchase things for yourself and let me
give it to you in a lesson that i
learned from my own mother
and i've told this story countless of
times countless times countless times
my mother georgette was a working girl
in her 20s she worked at a factory owned
by her father that made
children's winter clothing she would
save 20 percent
of her salary each week and invest it
but it's not all she did with it she
loved fashion too
she loved clothing she liked to buy
things for herself
but she had a different mindset about it
she told me years later and this really
changed the way i think about buying
stuff
that she would save a whole year just to
buy
one jacket instead of buying a whole ton
of cheap stuff
that she would throw out a year later
and maybe not even wear
she would save up for one thing that she
really wanted
she loved chanel so when it came to
clothing
she loved chanel jackets they cost a
fortune back then
but they were very high quality and they
looked beautiful and her thinking was
they last forever in your wardrobe
chanel never goes out of style now
talking about
style and talking about fashion in
georgette's mind was it really
is who you are you're presenting
yourself to the world and you want to
look good you want to feel good about
yourself
the reason i tell you that story and why
it's so powerful to me
is years later when she passed away and
i became the executive for her estate
i started getting phone calls from all
the women in my extended family saying
what happened to georgette chanel
jackets
what do you mean what happened to them
they're hanging up
in the wardrobe well i would like one of
them
in fact i'd like them all and i began to
realize that these jackets
were classics all the women were
fighting over them they all wanted the
chanel jackets why they were worth more
today than they were 30 years ago
because they were one of a kind in some
cases classic chanels
how brilliant georgette was how genius
that was
she invested in herself in something she
really loved that appreciated in
value that's what i'm talking about i
want you to start thinking that way
now let's go back and listen to ralph
lauren
a guy that understands style and
investing listen to what he said years
ago
you'll appreciate this
so
i
you get it right he's talking about how
you want to present yourself to the
world
so my whole theory about
fashion is it's about you it's how you
want to present yourself so you have two
options you can buy a whole bunch of
crap you don't wear all the time
cheap clothing a lot of people go that
way or you can start investing
in pieces that are going to appreciate
in style that really means something to
you
now i'm dressed up in a suit today the
one you see me in all the time why do i
dress in this black suit well it's my
uniform
years ago a very savvy wardrobe director
when we were shooting shark tank over 10
years ago said
kevin you look good in a black suit
white shirt black tie
maybe a little classic coutramal like a
tie pin
make it a standard and you'll never have
to shoot outtakes because when you shoot
shark tank and you change your outfit
at the end of that shooting day you have
to do outtakes because those shows are
put together they're stitched together
you might shoot one deal on a tuesday
and another deal on a friday
and they end up in the same show but if
you change your clothing
it's harder for the editors and you've
got to do a lot more post-production
work by having the standard uniform i
wear
i avoid all that wasted time great
lesson for me but it also became sort of
my signature look in business
it's crisp it's easy so i invested in
myself and my look
i have 25 of these jackets 25 pants 25
taipei's 25 black ties
25 handmade shirts it's an investment
it's not junk it's very valuable to me
you should think about your clothing
that way too think the way georgette did
buy one thing you really love that you
know you're going to wear
but it's not just clothing okay i want
to talk about another asset class let's
take for example watches everybody knows
i collect watches
this is another situation where you can
buy something for yourself
love it because you love the style of it
and then over time during your life it
appreciates in value
can it be material appreciation oh yeah
now i'm wearing today
a rolex steel white face daytona
an entry level watch not excessively
expensive
but you know a stylish piece from rolex
now
i have many different brands and i'm not
endorsing rolex one over another
i love grand seiko i love patek i love
eddie more piquet
i love all kinds mings micro brands
vacheron you name it
i have these watches in my collection
for a reason i love to collect them but
i also am investing
i'm thinking long term now how much are
watches worth over time
i'm going to give you an extreme example
i want you to watch this video about
a daytona which is why i wore this one
today bought in the 70s for just around
400 bucks
or under 500 anyways and then what is it
worth today
you might get a real kick out of this
now this is an extreme example but i
want to point out to you the idea
of investing in yourself in pieces you
love
that can appreciate over time i brought
in a rolex watch that
i had purchased while i was in the
military
i flew on air america airlines
and continental airlines and i noticed
that most of the pilots that were
flying those aircraft wore rolex watches
and i was intrigued by them i always
wanted to purchase them but they were
very expensive later when i was
transferred to another base
i did some scuba diving and i knew that
the rolex watch was good for scuba
diving
i found this particular watch
where i could afford it and i never used
it i looked at it and i said you know
this is really too nice to take down in
a
salty water i just kept it and this
particular model being marked oyster
is extremely extremely rare basically
it's a new old stock watch
no wear on it the original foil sticker
on the back of it
and the fact that we have all this
complete documentation here also
maybe one of the very few in the whole
world that still was never worn
your watch at auction today
five hundred to seven hundred thousand
dollars
now how crazy is that
four hundred and change to seven hundred
thousand dollars during a man's lifetime
yes it can happen that's an extreme
example but my point is these watches do
appreciate
in fact paul newman's you heard
reference to in that video sold for 17.5
million
your watch may not do that but the point
is over time a beautiful time
piece that you love that you invested in
for yourself
goes up in value i'll give you another
example i love guitars
now here's a guitar um
this is it's a one of a kind guitar
it was made for me by the guys at benji
locke one of my shark tank companies
it's a beautiful piece
ec 401 with this special paint mr
wonderful screaming at you i love that
but i also love to play it now this is
another excuse for me just to mess
around and i love doing it but i'm
trying to make a point about another
asset class
guitars they're beautiful they're fun
you can play them you can learn how to
play them
[Music]
you know just messing around but that's
the whole idea
i love the guitar is this guitar going
to be worth more
20 years from now i think it will be now
let me give you an example
those of you that love guitars know
what a gibson les paul is it's a classic
guitar and rock and roll
you've seen it played by some of the
biggest rockers of all time
designed by a guy named les paul well
les paul recently passed away
he used to play at a jazz club called
the iridium in new york
i loved him i loved all he did in that
and he was a grammy winner as well not
only for music but also for inventions
around music
multi-track recorders that kind of thing
les paul's a legend for that
i went to seem at the radium and i
brought my les paul
to les paul to ask les paul to sign my
les paul
and he did here he is signing it now
what do you think that guitar is worth
today not only do i still
play it i love to have it but it's
signed by less to me
my whole point is to talk about
investing in yourself
and thinking wisely about how you spend
your money you don't have to be spartan
you don't have to starve yourself from
the joys of life
you have to think pragmatically buy less
stuff
but when you buy stuff make it good
stuff make it investable stuff
whether it be a watch whether it be a
guitar
even something like a ballpoint pen
yeah you can spend 29 cents on a pen and
throw it away or you can buy
a collectible piece like this one a
mobile
they only make so many of them and over
time they appreciate in value
and they're wonderful to have this is a
collectible
it's it's a design around egyptian
hieroglyphics
it's etched on the body of the pen now
you may say that's triton stupid i don't
think so
it's stylish i love to use it it's
functional pragmatic
and it's appreciating in value you know
i gift
pens to people in business very rare
pens sometimes
to celebrate a deal they really
appreciate it and when they look back
five years later when that
pen has gone out of production it's
enhanced in value dramatically
i want you to think that way buy less
stuff
but buy good stuff that means something
to you
that too my friends is investing in the
future
take care